je m'appelle lucile j'ai tout juste 21
ans je vis dans une petite commune année
sur serein d'environ 240 habitants dans
l'yonne
et c'est ici qu'il y a deux ans j'ai
créé mon entreprise de marocains
[Musique]
eh bien nous voilà dans le côté boutique
vous pouvez voir toutes mes petites
créations et maintenant je vous invite à
venir voir mon atelier où je passe la
plupart de moteur
[Musique]
mon travail je crée je répare et je
rénove donc là par exemple
ce sacre ont gelé imaginé et maintenant
voilà je suis en train de le finir
il faut vraiment savoir tout faire entre
guillemets
je m'entraîne encore à de nouvelles
techniques
il faut avoir de l'imagination bien
évidemment pour pour réaliser toujours
des choses qui sont uniques
j'ai fait un bac pro métiers du cuir
option maroquinerie issoudun dans
l'indre
je suis parti là bas trois ans j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses j'ai rencontré
des gens très intéressants et j'ai fait
aussi des stages chez bitton aussi à
paris en cordonnerie ma main je peux
faire un zigzag sucrés salés de subway
merci
[Musique]
je pensais pas que ce serait mise à son
compte aussi rapidement
donc c'est une des contraintes bien
évidemment pas ce qu'il faut faire il
faut suivre
mais bon voilà c'est une fierté que moi
être jeune aujourd'hui et faire ce que
je fais à mon âge c'est pas facile du
tout il faut il faut le dire j'ai eu
très peur au début
effectivement et toujours l'appréhension
mais mais il faut qu'ils tentent en rien
à rien comme on dit donc il faut se
lancer
et puis si je tombe je pourrais je suis
jeune je peux rebondir derrière ont
trouvé du travail dans mon métier
cool ici comme si ça marche ça marche
c'est en fait un bon stage de découverte
en troisième je me suis rendu compte en
fait la maroquinerie c'était une
vocation c'est là où j'ai eu vraiment le
déclic je savais vraiment que je voulais
faire ça une fois il faut il faut
vraiment être courageux pour se lancer
dans une aventure comme ça c'est pas
évident parfois avec mon mari on se dit
si on avait 20 ans aujourd'hui en france
je ne sais pas si on aurait le courage
de se lancer dans une aventure comme
celle ci parce que les contraintes sont
très lourdes
et
et que vraiment dans leurs temps de
loisirs c'est peut-être qu'un rêve mais
j'aimerais être concurrents de lobito ou
ernest j'aimerais bien pouvoir faire
défiler messac la fashion week à paris
etc
mais le siège l'implantation principale
restera dans l'yonne et à la campagne ce
que j'ai toujours vécu ici et j'ai un
attachement bien particulier à ce
monde-là